Gut health is so important to me,
which is why I started taking SEED a few years ago.
This is the seed DSO one sinbiotic.
Started looking into gut health when I struggled with having eczema.
So I had really bad eczema for a few years,
and one of the things that I knew was gonna help
was figuring out my gut health.
So then I looked into taking probiotics,
and I found SEED,
which is actually a pro and prebiotic,
made such a difference in how my gut feels,
which impacts my skin health as well.
It also comes with this little travel size.
I'm not traveling anytime soon,
but when I do travel,
I pop some of these in there,
and it's so easy to take.
I just take two capsules in the morning before my breakfast,
and that's about all I do.
This DSO one symbiotic has impacted my gut health so much,
so if you're looking for something,
it's definitely worth looking into.
I could not go a single day without using this.